Today's video dance mom. When I watched this show, you know what I thought,
go ahead. How is this legal <laugh>?
How is this legal? Yeah. And how is this legally broadcasted more than anything?
Um, dance mom is a show that appeared on TV.
I believe it was on TLC.
And basically we're following a dance studio that does
classical dance and their dance moms with their kids.
And that's pretty much what it is. I wanna,
I wanna kind of showcase you to you guys, like a, I'm gonna play the video.
I want you guys to understand like the kind of relationship that students have
with their dance teacher. I, and that parents have with the dance teacher.
It's very, very bizarre. Come on.
This, is it ready up, up?
I, the.
I did not sign up to kiss G and it's a little awkward for me because
he likes me.
Oh Jesus. Every time I watch that clip,
every time I watch that clip.
There, you.
She just wiped her lips up. She did. Aw,
Maddie and Abby both had their first kiss the same day. That's kind of sweet.
Twins. Yeah. I'm disgusting. This is illegal. Yeah. I'm disgusted.
This child said, no, I don't want to.
And this adult that was not her guardian or her parent did that to her now,
obviously, because it's a woman as a society, we tolerate this kind of behavior.
Are you matching women again? Whatever.
Imagine the message you're sending to young women about the kind of boundaries
that they should set for themselves.
Imagine about the message you're sending young women about how
they should value their body and their autonomy. Look, my first kiss,
wasn't special. A lot of my friends' first kiss wasn't special,
but for some people, something that they want to say,
something that they want for a specific person for you to come in
and to take that from someone,
because you want your dance routine to work well,
where is the consent in this? Oh, nowhere. The answer is nowhere. There was no,
no. How is this on YouTube, Ralph bro.
I watched that Netflix movie that everyone freaked out about.
This is more disturbing the than that. Yeah,
because the movie that you watch was a movie. This is, this happens.
Is this cute to you guys? Do you guys find this like acceptable?
There's a lot of that. People put their lips, like if that's my daughter B,
we go on court or we fine. If you did that in front of my kid,
you getting you getting fist, we fighting man, or woman, we fighting,
you put your lips on her mouth. We fight. And those other mothers, oh,
that's a different top that that's something else. And we go get to that.
They enabled that.
I remember watching this scene and I felt like it kind of encapsulated how
we ingratiate kids in dance,
how we teach them how to dance, what we teach them, what to accept.
It's just a microcosm, but a very negative, um,
example of how we socialize young people to not learn about consent,
to not learn about boundaries,
to not learn about what abuse looks like.
Yes. That's, that's the oof. Yes, yes. It, it, it is.
It is quite a frightening scene, to be honest with you.
And you look at the likes and the comments and people are joking around and I'm
like, this is disturbing. Mm-hmm <affirmative>, you know,
and then people grow up older and they don't how to communicate their
boundaries. And when it comes from their childhood,
you violated those boundaries. Oh, you can. And every,
every adult in the room laughed,
you could my name right now because you're just preaching right now. Go ahead.
For me, it was very difficult to watch,
but it just rep presented what I had seen, always in dance.
So I felt the need to kind of keep calm just because I'm like, yo,
but you've seen this. You've seen it different forms, but you've seen this.
I've seen this exactly. I've seen dance.
Teachers put their hands on people when they shouldn't.
I think that's probably why when that Netflix stuff happened and everything
popped off, I'm like, bro, y'all need to look in your backyards.
Y'all had 13 seasons on TLC and it only last year.
And I can assure you,
anything you would've seen in that movie is not even half as bad as what you'll
see on those episodes. In terms of outfits, in terms of choreography,
in terms of how suggestive it does in terms, how in danger,
they put these kids in, in terms of how they violate their boundaries.
There's an episode where they force a young girl to go on a date with a boy that
she does not want to go with. What?
I think she's like 13 or 14 because she wants the teacher wants the dance
routine to have great dance chemistry. The number.
Is called snapshot.
And I think we need to bring a boy in to be the photographer. What do you think?
Raw <laugh>
broken brand interacting really weird during the group number,
doing their partnering. Brandon.
When I say the word I want chemistry between you, what does,
what does that mean? I mean,
you have to have like emotion between each other and just the passion that you
like, feel something, right? Like this girl makes your heart stop. Yes.
What does it mean to you? Same thing. <laugh>
now do the arch back
and look back at him and slide slow.
Lovely.
I think some of the moves on snapshot were a little risque watching Brooke and
Brandon in rehearsal is like waiting for pace to get sticky. SHNE out.
There's nothing happening. Nothing. You and Brandon
are carrying this number. So I need chemistry. I need something.
And if you two wouldn't mind, I'm gonna send them on a date. What.
Do you think about Abby sending us.
Here? She's weird.
You can understand where she's coming from though, right? No. With the dance.
I've been trying to connect with Brooke the whole week,
but she he's been pretty cool toward.
<Laugh>.
In what world is forcing a teenager,
a child to go on romantic dates,
something acceptable on television.
It's crazy how they're gonna put advertisement on that advertise,
but they're gonna put advertisement on that prime time. Prime time,
prime time shows advertisement on that. But whenever we do comedy skits,
comedy jokes, comedy, right?
The people that are gonna review my comedy,
if it goes on to TV is not another comedian or a comedian in sheep.
It is gonna be a lawyer, but nobody, no,
no one crickets. All right,
cool. It's pretty disturbing. I've seen exactly that happen. Parenting.
There's a certain level of like narcissism in my it's really relevant in,
in these parents. Um,
you could tell that a lot of dance parents live vicariously through their
kids and whatever failed dreams and aspirations they had.
They impose on their children and expect their children to achieve,
even if their kids would want or don't want to be in dance.
Those parents are pushing those kids.
And that's why they tolerate watching a stranger or someone who's not part of
their family kiss their child. When I see this,
I see extreme forms of narcissism. And,
and these are the people who are mentoring these young kids,
these dance teachers don't care, cuz they just want to win.
And so they'll engage in all kinds of behavior.
They're parents are just as bad as sometimes they want to win even more than the
teacher itself. Yep. You understand what I'm saying? Yep. So yes,
the teacher engages in that.
They don't say a thing because they also are in that same mindset. Yes.
It's like, remember when you said to yourself, you know, you were watching, uh,
Neverland or whatever, whatever. And they're like,
how can a parent just give your child? Like it happens every day.
Mm-hmm <affirmative> every day.
I'm not saying that every dance school is like that, but it happens a lot. Yep.
A lot. Yep.
Hopefully I know a lot of dance calls that do not proceed in these kind of
behaviors, but I know a lot, a whole lot more, unfortunately, that do.
Yep. Because of what competition,
because you want that prize because you want that fame at the end,
you want that money that mm.
That ooph and the parents are even worse than the teachers.
You want to be disturbed,
go look up some dance competitions online right now and watch what they're
wearing. Watch the poses that they get into.
And the suggestive nature of a lot of their dance moves.
And it happens at very young ages,
very young ages. You might not have all the zoom ins,
but it's still just as awkward. And it goes on for just as long. Hmm.
Look at these outfits, look at them and tell me,
how is this in any way acceptable lace. That's what it is.
Lace how a kid is gonna have a lace on your outfit. We have, we have,
we have 10 year olds dressing like grown women.
And he's a thing Lepar prince and lace
that's whole linger. Like perhaps there's one,
there's a couple athletes where they're just literally in booty shorts.
And I know that's what I'm talking about. That's he lingers Ray. But anyways,
that's just doing burlesque, but we're gonna burlesque at that age.
There there's some dances.
There's some dances that I would not going to teach a certain,
you know what burlesque is? Do you know what I mean? Like, dude,
they understand when you're making the 'em do this. Like,
and some of these kids,
they start dancing because they see someone dance and they want to dance and
start really has fun. Mm-hmm <affirmative> it really starts as being fun.
And then the parents get in once the parents are there and they put
that pressure on the kids that be good to be whether it's dance,
whether it's hockey, it's soccer, it's football.
Sometimes watching these parents talk mm-hmm <affirmative> to their kids
right about other kids.
Is that first thing first is just talking to your kids certain way.
That's a messed up.
That's I've seen messed up things happen and messed up way of talking to a kid
that nobody should be talk like that. And that's come from,
that comes from a Haitian dude.
That's been racist by a Haitian parents that my parents call me a whole bunch of
names, but they never called me a lot of things that they,
these kids were called then,
and of this character information that you're talking about. Another kid talk,
look, look at this little, wow.
Look at us like talking to them like they're <laugh> well,
you shouldn't even say that to grown humans. I have to judge.
And sometimes, you know, when you, when you judge hip hop,
they have to censor music because they can't dance on certain words.
Right? But even if you don't dance on certain words, I remember the,
as a group of teens, a group of teen, like early young,
young kids and they were dancing on hip hop and they were dancing on Lil John.
All the bad words were all the bad words were censored.
But even when you censor bad words,
it's still bad to the window, to the wall, to the sweat,
go down my balls. Now, listen, I didn't say one bad word to the sweat.
Go down my ball that I have kids dancing on that. All them crawl.
I didn't say I, I, I removed the word,
keep Keke ski to youth or the people that don't know. It's not a bad word,
but the people that know what ske skite is.
It's not the sound that you make when you go down a Hills key ski
love mom I'm skiing.
When you thought that one you were like this fire. Well,
I could tell when he thought this, he was like, I'm a nail. This I,
I could tell this.
Woo, that's going out that hill mom, did you meet,
did you see mama ice all over?
Can you imagine just like redefining cross country skiing,
just going across the country. Just skiing everywhere. <laugh>
I think at this point, I'm not even gonna explain what skit is.
I'm gonna let y'all read the comments, but you have kids dancing on that. Okay?
It's not a random word.
You learn character information at a young age. Yep.
And if you do dance very early, you, you learn it very,
the position of a dance. You know, our dance routine is kind of a pyramid.
All right. It's kind of like this mm-hmm <affirmative> and the more,
the most precious position is the one in the middle, in, on top of the pyramid.
Right.
And all the sides and in the back is like the bottom of the pyramid. Right?
I've seen, I've seen parents fight.
I ain't talking about words physically because their
child was not on the first spot.
And I starts with character defamation.
These kids don't even have problem with each other. Hey, listen,
I see crazy parents at baseball games, differences.
At least those kids are fully clothed.
<laugh> at least those kids are not subjected to the same thing that dancers
are. It's a different ball game. It's different. It's a different ball game.
And it it's very disturbing what's going on. Mm-hmm <affirmative> and you know,
there's a larger discussion to be had about the example
that society's setting for women in general,
the expectations of beauty that men and women are encouraging
on women.
These young girls are not dressing like this to because they're rebellious or
this and that and blah, blah, blah. No, it's because they love on Instagram.
They see what's popping and they try to emulate.
What's grown because everyone who's young wants to grow up faster than they can.
Everyone says, let kids be kids. Kids don't even want to be kids,
kids trying to grow up. Am I lying? Mm-hmm <affirmative>. And so
there's an even larger problem about the messaging and the kind of
role models that we're providing for young children.
And I'm just talking about ladies,
this is not a knock on ladies and how they I'm talking about men as well and
what they choose to value.
There has to be a discussion on how our societal values and our sense of
individualism. And like my choice is my choice. All right, well, listen,
that trickles down, right? Cause cuz young kids are watching your,
your choice is your choice. Yeah.
Young kids are watching and they're emulating they're emulating.
So understand what that means and understand that,
how you care yourself and how you choose to act every day. All right.
That has an impact on younger people.
So there's a,
a very difficult and nuanced discussion to have about that as well. I don't,
I'm not one of those people thinking, well, if you get rid of dance,
these kids are gonna stop dress. No, I know they won't stop.
I know because I know they're connected to the internet.
I know what they're looking at and we're not saying to get rid of dance.
That's not the problem. No dances is a dancing is a it's great.
It's a wonderful thing. You have to watch how you do it and what you instill in,
in people's mind how you do it and what you convey.
What is the message that you put out there when you do the things that you do in
that wonderful art? That it's a wonderful thing. It's great thing.
I was able to do a lot of things with dance. I'm not even on it. That's not,
that's not the point. If that's what you understood. Yep. Then you're wrong.
You understood wrong. That's not.
You have to understand what you try to convey to people how the
value, right? Yep. Do you value value or whatever it is,
you have to see which you bring to the people.
There are studios that do this ethically.
There are organizations that are actually fighting for the protection mm-hmm
<affirmative> of children within dance because they recognize that it's a
growing problem that we're seeing all over this country. So be aware,
know that it's all around. You know, that it's happening constantly.
All of us kids were signed up for dance classes who are doing things within
schools and part of troops pay attention. Notice what's going on.
Have those discussions. Cause I'm telling you,
if you think that was a form of exploitation, this is a,
so an area where there's zero consent,
where the influence is not in the child's best interest whatsoever and
where the child's needs come second at most times,
if you are okay with that, if you turn a blind eye of that, to me,
it seems slightly hypocritical. Anyways, that's it for today's video.
We want to hear your thoughts leaving in the comments below.
You.